I definitely loved you and there still
you have to occupy a huge space in my
heart you know yeah my relationship was
pretty good at least in the beginning I
I considered you my best friend so it's
best way to sum it up your own best
friend I always loved spending time with
you
and after everything I felt like I lost
the best friend to me our relationship
was also a little bit fiery because I
wasn't exactly someone that you know
people thought you would be dating
you're you know Pepperdine college girl
and you know Christian and I am college
dropout and not Christian yeah I don't
think anyone expected us to be together
we're very different there was nothing
to cause at the breakup it's like none
of us cheated on each other or anything
like that it was just kind of a mutual
falling out of love and we both wanted
to do different things we're doing
different places in our life and I think
it happened over the course of a couple
months and just start progressively
feeling more and more often and it was
more fighting and I think a big part of
is also you have such a jealousy issue
oh you do - yeah but like you have it to
an unhealthy degree yeah but you do -
but you more so what do you do - because
our relationship wasn't really bad it
wasn't it wasn't bad
I definitely loved you and there's still
you have to occupy a huge space in my
heart you know
[Music]
I don't know the first moment I fell in
love with you like even on our first
date you found some guy's wallet on the
floor you made us not go on the date so
you could return it and I thought that
was the sweetest thing in the world
now I remember when I said I love you oh
yeah we made some delicious Brussels
sprouts by taking a Trader Joe's package
and some random random vegetables just
combine them I don't know I was like I
love this girl and I think that
Thanksgiving night was the day I was
brave enough to kind of tell you I love
you I think the moment for me when I
realized that I loved you it may sound
silly but it was the day you let me
drive your car okay because then I knew
you truly trust me I was like wow you
hundred percent trust me and I think I'm
falling for him what was it you told me
about the love languages acts of service
quality time words of affirmation gifts
and physical touch and my love language
was definitely quality time in years was
gifts my love languages actually acts a
service and then gifts I don't know I
really don't know I remember a lot of
happy moments but the same time I still
remember the bad moments I had with you
and the reason you were making me oh
happy
I just think about that and there
reminds me why our relationship need to
end it I don't know if there's a chance
of us getting back together our minds
are set up like
you know us we're pretty set in our ways
yeah I'm pretty stubborn thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]